The answer is no, that's not correct at all.
I've been cheating a little along the way in that I've been showing you solutions
that I got the second or third time once I'd debugged them and got them right.
This time I wanted to show you a little bit of the debugging process.
I got something wrong here. I don't always get them right the first time.
This is so wrong looks what's happening.
I said the first move is at the 5 and the 2 go across together.
It seems like a perfectly reasonable move. They're going from here to there.
The second move was that the 1, by his or herself, comes back from there to here.
But 1 isn't even over there. How could 1 come back?
I must have messed up the successor function. Let's take a look.